it stinks
there's nothing virtual about it the bad
smell in the air is very real but this
farmer doesn't mind no bazookas
biological gas plant is bubbling along
nicely today with organic materials
rotting and fermenting and stinking it
means that there's a good amount of gas
going into the generators which then
produces electricity the Bugis coal is
the electricity from biogas is the most
expensive of the renewable energies so
you really have to get the most out of
it its main advantage is the
controllability of this form of power
production because you can store the gas
in the gas membranes I have a personal
and idealistic reason for helping to
establish Network stability in order to
take advantage of the edge that the
biogas sector has so biogas provides
predictable electricity
unlike wind turbines there are several
of those around Yuka's farm today
they're spinning but yesterday they
stood still that's why Duke has rotting
manure makes up an important building
block in a much larger complex together
more than 1,000 small facilities form
one large power plant they're owned by
farmers like Dukas with solar roofs wind
turbines biogas generators together
there is powerful as a nuclear plant how
does that work the secret is in these
two floors at an old factory building in
Cologne there's no generator no turbines
just computers that make up a virtual
power plant it's a data processing
center only it's calculating electricity
output the only physical thing is this
box it connects all the facilities
outside to the mainframe and adds up the
energy that's fed into it the engineer
has a lot to do right now because more
people want to get involved in but this
is more than who needs it and the Box
communicates through this modem and
sends the data to the guidance system or
the guidance system can transmit signals
to that
communicating small power plants each
one individually controllable to young
economists came up with the idea 5 years
ago they had the old coal-fired plants
in their sights
today they trade some 100 million euros
worth of electricity and are making a
profit I know I behind a games on this
team fun we want renewable energies to
take over system responsibilities the
appropriate system has to be created for
that so that the renewables can do what
they do best which is make up for
temporary fluctuations in the power grid
that was our jumping-off point where we
said we could Network a lot of renewable
energy plants which can even out
fluctuations and they can take over the
same network output the conventional
plants used to provide and it works is
fortunate here a new biogas facility is
still just a pin on a map because it has
to be tested can it be easily
remote-controlled the farmers let their
small facilities be adjusted from
outside that makes their electricity
marketable so it's worth it back with
farmer Dukas as a provider of green
energy he also drives an electric car
powered by his own electricity
he thinks the network solution is
brilliant today with so much wind and
Sun his gas isn't in such demand back in
Cologne his output is reduced and he's
given financial compensation this down
regulation can vary a lot sometimes
there isn't one for two weeks then it
happens 10 times a day it depends on
network demand with this farmer the
usually silent electricity also gets its
own sound in the form of a bug zapper in
the pigsty the ideal ecological cycle is
shown here the liquid manure goes into
the biogas facility and produces
electricity corn is added and the
fermentation substrate is sprayed on the
fields as fertilizer this closed-loop
system which has been used since the
Middle Ages gives my business a great
deal of stability and is ecologically
valuable info
the weather forecast for the next few
days is for rain and very little wind
that means Dukas smelly electricity will
be in demand again